Hey YouTubers. It's Charlie. So this is going to be my Flash episode nineteen video.
Also kind of like a soft cross over with Arrow, just like we had last week.
I know everyone was playing up the episode eighteen all-star team up episode as the big cross over but
this was actually really big too for reasons that we'll get into during spoilers.
So just careful if you haven't seen the episode yet
and yay for Green Lantern pizza.
OK so here we go starting with top five WTF moments.
Number Five: Cisco gives Laurel her Canary Cry.
One of the biggest questions I've gotten all season is
will there be another particle accelerator explosion,
and will Laurel get Canary Cry powers as result of that?
This is the answer. She's basically using tech.
If you ever watch Young Justice, you know Canary wears the choker.
Think of this as like a tech version of that.
Cisco explains that this is super beefed up
so it'll be super bad ass. They'll probably use it before the end of the season.
Because the episodes are staggered I don't know when we're going to see this
being used in an episode of Arrow. It might be like
Arrow episode twenty-two. It might even be like the finale.
The picture that Laurel gave to Cisco is the funniest thing in the world.
He's like the biggest
Black Canary super fan.
Let me know which picture you think is funnier. Cisco's picture with the Black Canary,
or the picture of Steven Amell
like the actor head shot they used. The Glamour Shot
in episode nineteen.
On to number four: meet Hannibal Bates
a.k.a. Everyman from the comics.
If you're not familiar with the character, Everyman
came around the Infinite Crisis time in the comics.
Lex Luthor created a program
called The Everyman Project
where he gave powers to people that wanted them.
It was part of his secret plot to control people with super powers like
he could take away their powers with the push of a button.
Obviously we're not going to see Lex Luthor on The Flash so
this is just like The Flash's version of Hannibal Bates.
It's interesting that he can't remember who he really is. He's changed into so many people.
Also when Harrison said that it's meant to highlight the balance between
the original Harrison Wells
and Eobard Thawne inside that one body.
The producers said that when the Reverse Flash
sucked in all of Harrison Wells
it kind of melded their minds a little bit together so there
is some of the original Harrison Wells mind inside that body.
It will probably explain how they can defeat the Reverse Flash at the end of the season but
Tom Cavanagh doesn't have to leave the show.
That's going to get really timey-wimey.
As a source of villainy Hannibal Bates, not such a
threatening villain. I think he's better for comedy.
Like the "snowbarry" kiss for instance, that was a really funny moment,
especially with the music cues they used behind it,
you knew that it was going to be a funny thing.
I was actually tweeting during the episode about how it was funny that Danielle Panabaker
didn't have the classic "slap reaction" that you would expect
like "how dare you kiss me? what's wrong with you?"
It was a couple minutes after it happened, it was by the time Caitlin had made it back to Barry's house and found him in the closet.
Cut to her slapping him to wake him up.
Think of it as like a delayed slap reaction.
I'm not like a huge shipper on the show but it is funny when they sneak in moments like that.
We do have an idea where Cailtin and Firestorm's characters are going so
if you've seen those spoilers just please use spoiler tags if you're going to comment on them.
The real question we need to ask now is will Harrison Wells
co-opt Hannibal's services in the finale or before the finale?
It just seems like he might release a lot of meta-humans to run interference on Team Flash
while he's enacting whatever his evil final plan is.
On to number three: Eddie reveals to Iris that he's been working with The Flash.
This whole thing with Iris not knowing is causing more problems than it's solving.
That was what that whole car escape scene was about.
Iris demanded they take Hannibal to the police station
because she didn't understand what a threat he was.
Eddie telling Iris is just the tip of the iceberg.
He hasn't explained anything yet.
Iris is aware that meta-humans exist. She just doesn't know the
full extent of what's going on.
There are four more episodes in the season so I'd say by the next two or three episodes
she'll have it pretty much figured out.
That doesn't include finding out that Barry is The Flash though.
That's probably going to be some other big WTF moment.
She'll probably figure it out on her own. Barry won't just take his mask off and reveal himself.
If she's going to be a reporter and the writers want us to take her as a character seriously,
then logically she should be able to do the detective work to figure out
that Barry is The Flash on her own.
When Candice Patton was talking about her character she called out Lois Lane and in Man of Steel
Lois Lane figured out that Clark Kent was Superman on her own.
Really early in the movie actually.
Moving on to number two: Team Flash finds Harrison Wells' original body.
I like how they bought Quentin into the episode. Like Joe and Quentin have this "dad cop"
bro-out moment.
"You would do anything to save your daughter if you could."
Quentin knows something is up. He knows there's a dead body. He knows it's probably Harrison Wells.
He just doesn't know the full extend of what's going on with the meta-humans,
and he doesn't know that Barry is The Flash.
I think he knows that something really weird is going on because
everyone saw his coffee rising out of the cup
but he doesn't have the context to understand what the larger ramifications of it are.
Showing Caitlin the body too I think won her over. For most of the episode there was a big question as to
whether or not she was going to try and side with Harrison Wells
and not believe Barry.
I think seeing the body was the metaphorical slap in the face that she needed.
and finally my number one WTF moment:
Team Flash makes it inside the Gideon computer room,
and Harrison Wells is inquiring with Eddie Thawne.
This is like our big endgame moment so Team Flash
sees the Reverse Flash suit
and sees the future newspaper "Flash disappears in crisis"
and then over on the other side of town,
Harrison Wells is slowly moving in on Eddie Thawne.
So let's start with the Gideon computer room stuff.
Seeing the yellow suit was a big WTF
but really I think the bigger surprise for them was seeing the newspaper from the future.
They don't know who Eobard Thawne is. They don't know that he's from the future.
What I think that crisis might be is The Flash disappearing
because he went back in time to chase The Reverse Flash
to the night that his mother was murdered.
That might be what that is originally from.
Moving over to the police station, what is Eobard Thawne's plan for Eddie Thawne?
Is he going to try and co-opt his services?
Eddie, right now, is a good person.
He is friends with Barry. Very good friends with Barry and Team Flash.
That means that The Reverse Flash is going to have to trick
Eddie or force Eddie to help him.
Which means he might start going after Iris.
Iris would be the way to do that.
That's a very classic Reverse Flash thing.
Threatening to kill the wife or girlfriends of The Flash over the years.
So with that in mind, here's my big question for you guys.
What do you think that Eobard Thawne's plan is for Eddie Thawne?
I think I've said it before but what I think the show is moving towards
is a big WTF moment
where by Eddie Thawne will have a falling out with Barry Allen.
Slowly sowing the seeds
for Eddie to become a villain in a future season.
Whether that's season two, season three we have no idea.
There's still a whole bunch of stuff that hasn't happened this season. The Reverse Flash
still has all these meta-humans that he can unleash on Team Flash,
including Gorilla Grod. That's not for another two episodes though.
Next week is called "The Trap" so they're going to try and set a trap for The Reverse Flash.
Clearly I don't think anyone expects it to go well.
Be sure to subscribe to get that video.
What's going to happen next is I'm going to post my non-spoilery Avengers: Age of Ultron review.
Don't worry I'll post a spoilery version after the movie comes out worldwide. After May 1st.
Whole lot of "science bros". Gonna be a whole lot of fun so when ever I do post that video
please use spoiler tags if you're seeing it internationally and you're going to see it before everyone else.
While you guys wait for that to drop, you can click here for all my other Marvel/Avengers videos.
I'll add an annotation as soon as I post the video
and you can click here for all my other Flash videos.
Thank you so much for watching. Everybody lets high five. I'll see you guys tonight.